l'un n'empêche pas l'autre en fait
effectivement qu'il ya des gens qui se
mettent en danger
volontairement mécène même si on a eu un
rapport sexuel ça va même plus loin que
d'aller dans une chambre à quatre heures
du matin même si on a eu un premier
rapport sexuel on n'est pas forcé
d'accepter un deuxième ni un troisième
même si on avait eu 50 on n'est jamais
obligé ce camp sinon c'est non et
ça j'ai jamais eu ou non mais que faire
dans la sphère vous regarde ce que tu
oublie c'est que c'est une jeune femme
qui était vraiment qui était stagiaire
et qui était tout jeune qui est enfin
voilà ah oui mais c'est parole contre
parole n'y a pas de caméra y'a rien pour
l'instant on fait tomber un homme pour
l'instant pour quelle pour deux
personnes dans une piscine que personne
n'a vu sait tous que quand tu auras plus
de choses sur broadway sera le premier à
dire ok mais oui à rien béatrice comment
commence à voir comme dit mathieu si
voilà olala la jeune fille il ya quand
même elle voit qu'il ya eu des violences
ou là mais couvre lit où on a une
relation sexuelle une première fois on
n'a pas envie d'en avoir une deuxième si
et comment on fait ce que l'on fait pour
savoir en perdant la cas précis c'est
parole contre parole comment ça se passe
là c'est pas parole contre parole il ya
quand même des preuves bien sûr non mais
là dessus oui pour ça oui là dessus là
dessus c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des trucs
quand même voilà avec mathieu que pour
l'histoire de jean jacques bourdin
j'avais d'ailleurs été très choquée sur
l'attitude de valérie pécresse j'avais
j'ai été extrêmement choqué je suis pas
une fan de jean jacques bourdin loin de
là mais vraiment j'ai trouvé ça
déplorable cette façon de le prendre sur
le vif devant un public caressa pour
angers
canberra
lydia il estoit et mais il est au
courant qu'elle et lui dire
la première femme qui est laqué d'accord
avec moi là dessus c'est vrai c'est vrai
béatrice vous avez déjà eu lieu c'est
vrai que voilà est-ce que vous avez déjà
eu des des trucs des trucs lourd genre
des mecs qui vous disent de voile à
devenir non
austin par exemple je connais tous les
cas de figure je reconnais mes jeunes
femmes dont parle mathieu qui vont dans
la suite à cannes à 4 heures du matin
pour discuter contrat et j'ai aussi une
proposition d' harvey wine steen
d'aller à 2 heures du matin
j'ai refusé comment il a fait quand ils
vous envoyez un sms il n'a non pas du
tout on était un événement à l'époque
c'était oman rey assure au maghreb g non
c'est alors
il vient ferme en était un événement
donc avait beaucoup de monde et
heureusement qu'il y avait beaucoup de
monde autour et il me dit
en anglais est ce que tu veux me
rejoindre au ritz à telle heure et je
dis non merci et puis j'essaie d'être
polie de décliner en étant poli non
merci je suis fatigué je vais rentrer il
ya merci beaucoup et il me dit mais tu
sais qui je suis et tu veux continuer sa
carrière d'actrice donc voilà il y avait
du monde autour et heureusement parce
que je vois là sinon je ne sais pas et
je serai pas fait ça